what do you disagree about with peterson
you mentioned peterson's
conception of the
high school shooters is saying they
are objecting to god and you said well
that's correct in some sense there are
many many aspects where i don't uh
really agree with peterson it's i just
referred to him because he uh is one of
the few public intellectuals we have
left for better or verse right i'm
curious what ways do you defer we talked
about dennett and you you said you
disagree with him in some sense because
he's incomplete what about peterson
that's more commission right that's more
old mission rather than combination
uh i refer to peterson because he is a
common point of reference we all know
about him right now no that's fine
that's fine but i'm curious where you
disagree so um
and where you agree yes so uh yeah the
interesting thing is for for me when i
have to talk about disagreement because
disagreement is the default state
between minds isn't it it's only where
we can establish agreement when we are
independent thinkers where we see that
we uh understand things in the same way
so uh peterson thinks that the best way
to
interact with a cult that tries to be
state religion with some kind of
aggregor is to make a stand
and to expose yourself and uh
i am not sure if i agree with that so
basically he is fighting a culture war
in an ineffectual way i think
there is also a deeper level um peterson
thinks that growing up consists in
making a sacrifice
and the sacrifice is self-actualization
he would like to be happy but he cannot
afford to be happy but it was
incompatible with being an adult and
doing the things that adult has to do
and his sacrifice is incomplete
he has not sacrificed his need for
self-actualization
and that's why he appears to be so
bitter
right if he had made the sacrifice he
wouldn't be bitter
would sacrifice of self-actualization
yes so uh
he would become a priest
he would have that serene state of
somebody who has not lost anything
because he doesn't need anything what he
doesn't have
right this if you look at the archetypal
priest it's a person that is serene that
is smiling because they are at peace
with themselves and the world and they
might be suffering momentarily because
the unbelievers crucify him but apart
from the moments of uh
acute pain
or
the
moments of compassion for their flock
when they are involved in their dealings
with the world and try to help them and
fail at doing so because not all things
can be helped right the priest is
supposed to be okay with what he does
and peterson is not okay with what he
does he is suffering because he
uh has retained his identity
that the one that he thinks he has uh
sacrificed he hasn't
yes basically trying to understand i'm
trying to understand this so you're
saying that he has an identity and
because he's holding on to it it's like
a want and you should get rid of your
wants and then you'll be placid and
serene and tranquil
yes so he basically is doing something
that he has not fully internalized
himself
he is expressing the tension between
what he thinks he needs to be doing and
what he does
what he feels would reward him for doing
that right he he feels pain and doing
what he does
and uh there is of course this other
thing that
he is acting on certain incentives in
this game
and the question is are these incentives
completely pure
so he is a publicist that is filling a
certain niche a certain vacuum he is
trying to give people values
uh he's trying to a projectile authority
in a time that needs authority and he
might not be projecting exactly the
right authority or fitting authority but
he's interacting with the fact that the
millennials are the first generation
since
the
post-war generation that are
authoritarian again right every
generation after world war ii was
liberal